-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
[ Chuckles ] Wow.
Looking great.
Please, enjoy. Relax.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is a -- It's a special night
because, for the first time
since the pandemic,
our audience is no longer
required to wear a mask.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Smile!
You're on TV.
Yeah.
So, you better laugh
'cause I can see who isn't.
[ Laughter ]
What an exciting time this is.
We're maskless,
fully vaccinated,
and it's officially summer.
Official.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's great.
That's right. Kids are pumped
that school is over
while their parents are staring
blankly at a wall like,
"I thought we had more time."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and it's not just the
start of summer, you guys.
It's also Amazon Prime Day.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Today, instead of buying stuff
we don't need,
we buy stuff we don't need
at a slightly lower price.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what
an immersion blender is,
but, yeah, just look at
the price on that.
How am I gonna make my coffee
if I don't have
an immersion blender?
[ Laughter ]
Prime Day
is actually a two-day event.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, Amazon is basically
your annoying friend
who plans a "birthday weekend."
[ Laughter ]
"You only get one day, Carl."
Yep, Amazon has deals
on outdoor cameras,
digital recorders,
and night-vision binoculars.
And with that much
spying capability,
you're basically Amazon.
[ Laughter ]
You're at least Facebook.
Some news from Washington.
This weekend, Kim Jong-un
made his first statement about
the Biden administration,
saying that he's prepared for
both dialogue and confrontation.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Kim Jong-un just challenged
Biden to a rap battle.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Kim Jong-un says that he's
prepared for both dialogue
and confrontation.
It's the same thing my aunt says
when she walks into a T.J. Maxx.
[ Laughter ]
"Let's go!"
Well, guys, the Olympics
are almost here, and today,
organizers announced that venues
will be at 50% capacity.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right. 50%,
which means only four people
will be allowed to watch fencing
instead of the normal eight.
[ Laughter ]
En garde!
-Chh!
-Do they start
with the hand up here?
-Sure. Why not?
Yeah.
-Eventually -- I've seen this.
-Eventually, it's épée.
-But does it start --
Like this, maybe?
-Yeah, maybe that.
Maybe that.
That looks good.
You look good like that.
-I look like a fencer there.
-Yeah, a fencer
of stolen jewelry.
-Just being cocky.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to put a pinky out
on the sword.
-Yeah, I throw the pinky out.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, class.
There you go.
-Class it up a little bit.
-Pure class.
-Pinky out on the sword.
Like that?
Maybe like that?
-Yeah, like a flourish.
-Like a flour--
-Like jazz hands.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
-This is how you fence?
-Yeah.
♪♪
-That's how you fence?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
En garde!
Touché!
-Also, they also said fans
aren't allowed to cheer.
-Oh.
[ Light laughter ]
-Although they say that at the
beginning of every graduation,
and parents are still like,
"Thomas, yeah!
Whoo!
Tommy, you did it!
That's my boy, Tommy!"
[ Laughter ]
Soccer superstar
Cristiano Ronaldo just became
the first person in the world
to hit 300 million followers
on Instagram.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers ]
-It's a pretty big deal.
and now a lot of people
are reaching out
to congratulate him.
For example, Lionel Messi said,
"What an incredible achievement.
Way to go!"
[ Laughter ]
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson said,
"Congrats, pal,
but watch your back.
I'm coming for you."
[ Laughter ]
Then Ronaldo himself
had this to say.
He said, "I can't believe it.
Thank you so much
for the support."
[ Laughter ]
It didn't stop there.
Remember that statue of him?
-I knew it.
I knew it.
-Oh, no, it didn't --
-The bronze statue of Ronaldo
reached out and said...
-Really?
-"Ermagherd, yer nermber wern!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-After that, Ariana Grande said,
"I hope I can get
to 300 million soon."
And the statue of Ronaldo
was like, "Mer ter!
Er werna ber perpyerler!"
[ Laughter ]
Wants to be "perpular."
-"Perpular"?
-Then this plaque
of Elvis Presley spoke up
and said, "Yerr! Plers ferler
mer ern Ernstagrerm."
[ Laughter ]
And finally this statue
of Lucille Ball said,
"Mer herndle ers
@rerl-lercerlle-berl.
#Ferlerberk.
#Ernflererncer."
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're all very excited.
Good for him.
300 million is
nothing to sneeze at.
Listen to this.
I saw that NASA is struggling
to fix a computer on
the Hubble Space Telescope
that was developed in the 1980s.
Yeah.
It's from the '80s,
so the manual only says,
"Remove the circuit board
and blow on it."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a grocery store in
Wisconsin is offering customers
color-coded bracelets to show
their social-distancing
comfort levels.
Yeah, red means no contact.
Yellow means elbows only.
And green means open-mouth kiss.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
It just came out
that Trump's former bodyguard
is the latest member
of the Trump Organization
to be investigated
by New York prosecutors.
And get this.
The guy's name is --
And I'm not making this up.
The guy's name
is Matthew Calamari.
[ Laughter ]
Can we take a look
at Matthew Calamari?
-Yep.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. His name
had to be Matthew Calamari.
Looks like a bouncer
at Olive Garden.
[ Laughter ]
No word yet on Trump's
other bodyguards,
Johnny Meatballs,
Vinnie Calzone,
and Sammy Shrimp Scampi.
-Hey! Oh!
-Sammy Shrimp Scampi.
That's very good.
Well, guys, the White House says
that the country will need
a few extra weeks to hit
President Biden's goal
of 70% vaccination by July 4th.
That's right. The White House
wants to hit its goal so badly,
instead of fireworks,
they're just going to shoot
a bunch of Pfizer needles
into the sky.
[ Laughter ]
"Thank you!
That was beautiful.
That's the finale.
I think that's the finale now."
"No, no, no. Just wait."
"No, no, I know. That's it.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's the final--
It was Matthew Calamari."
[ Light laughter ]
According to projections, it
will be around 68% by July 4th.
Don't worry, though. Today --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today, Biden changed
the name of his plan
to Operation Close Enough.
[ Laughter ]
Well, some TV news --
last night was yet another
emotional episode
of "The Bachelorette."
We love that show,
and one of the --
[ Applause ]
I know. It's good.
One of the most memorable
moments
was when Hunter and Thomas
got into a heated argument
about whether Thomas was on the
show for the "right reasons."
If you missed it, don't worry,
because here
to re-enact that scene
with actual lines from the show
are The Roots' own
Tariq and Questlove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thanks, Jimmy.
Tonight I'll be playing Hunter,
a 34-year-old single father
from Texas
who's concerned that Thomas
is only here for fame,
not to find love, like I am.
-And I'll be playing Thomas,
a 28-year-old real-estate
broker from California
who doesn't feel like
he's doing anything wrong.
-Very good, guys.
Whenever you're ready.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-So, I hear the conversations
that are taking place
with you and other people,
and there's this flipping and
flopping and constant smiles.
I mean, it feels --
it feels almost like a campaign.
You know?
Like you want to be Bachelor.
I mean, is that something
you thought about?
[ Laughter ]
-I would never do anything
to hurt you,
so to feel that I come
across in any way that is --
This is the result --
-See?
See? That's the problem.
The -- I feel manipulated.
It just makes me really worried
about Katie
because you could be
doing the same thing with her.
And I would like to know --
have you ever thought
maybe I could end up
being the Bachelor?
♪♪
-I want to say
I appreciate you for being so --
-Has being the Bachelor...
crossed your mind?
[ Laughter ]
-I...don't have
the right answer bec--
-So is that your answer? Yes?
You are thinking about
being the Bachelor.
Is that what you were saying?
-Uh, look,
bef-- before coming here,
I didn't know what to expect.
-I'm not asking
what you expected-uh!
Was being the Bachelor...
Was that a prerogative for you?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
I can't be disingenuine
to you guys,
and I'm not gonna be.
So...yes.
Coming into this -- this --
I had thoughts in my mind
that I was potentially
gonna be the --
the next Bachelor.
-Like, that's messed up.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Touching. Thanks, guys.
Questlove and Tariq, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Gosh.
Whew. That was emotional.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news. Coors
just launched a new ice cream
that is infused
with their hard seltzer.
Yep. They didn't pitch that
on "Shark Tank."
They pitched that
on "Drunk Tank."
-Oh.
-You'll know it's good when
the ice-cream truck
accidentally pulls up
in your front lawn.
[ Steve imitates
tires screeching ]
And, finally, I saw that NASA
sent dozens of baby squid
from Hawaii to the International
Space Station for research.
-Ooh.
-And I also heard that
the mission is being led
by commander Matthew Calamari.
[ Laughter ]
Last night Senate Republicans
used the filibuster
to block a major voting rights
bill called
the For the People Act.
Yep, Democrats wanted things
like automatic
voter registration
and Election Day
to be a national holiday,
while Republicans wanted
every polling place
to be at a yacht club.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. They blocked
the For the People Act.
Senate Republicans
haven't been this happy
since Kenny G
started touring again.
[ Laughter ]
You can tell a lot of
Republican Senators are ashamed
that they blocked
the voting rights bill
'cause now they're scared
to be seen in public.
In fact, some of them are
even using body doubles.
For example, Senator Ben Sasse
is using his body double,
SpongeBob.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's getting
that serious.
Next up,
here's Senator Roy Blunt.
His body double is
Jack Nicholson's Joker.
[ Laughter ]
He doesn't want
to be seen in public.
-Wow. That's crazy.
-Senator Roger Marshall
is using his body double,
a pack of Chiclets.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they don't want to be --
-They don't want to be seen.
-Senator Rick Scott
is using his body double,
a human thumb.
[ Laughter ]
Just walking around.
-Wow. Oh, my gosh.
-Finally, of course,
Mitch McConnell
is using his body double,
Toby Turtle.
[ Laughter ]
It's just -- just to be safe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, listen to this.
I read that Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner
are trying to
distance themselves
from former president Trump
because they're tired of him
complaining about
losing the election.
When he heard that one of
his kids wanted distance,
Trump was like, "Please be Eric,
please be Eric."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is fun.
During his weekly address,
Pope Francis had a surprise
guest in the audience.
Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
Spider-Man.
Vatican security was like,
"Hey, I know we said everyone
should wear a mask, but this is
taking it to a whole new level."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the visit ended
when Spider-Man
kissed the Pope's ring
upside down.
-Oh.
-Kind of awesome.
[ Laughter ]
Well, Tinder rolled out
a new feature yesterday called
"Hot Takes," which lets singles
chat before matching.
And this is cool.
As an added bonus,
they're providing users
with a list of things
that you should avoid saying
during this introductory chat.
[ Laughter ]
For instance, things such as,
"Only three more days until
this ankle monitor comes off."
[ Laughter ]
Don't say that.
-Don't say it.
-Don't start with it,
at least, yeah.
Or how about this one?
"What do you know about
starting insurance fires?"
[ Laughter ]
-It's called Tinder.
-Yeah.
And finally, this one here,
"It's crazy,
but this is the only dating app
that hasn't banned me."
You shouldn't say those things
to open up.
[ Applause ]
Give it a little time.
Some more business news -- I saw
that budget airline Frontier
recently added
a COVID recovery charge
of $1.59 to passengers' tickets.
$1.59 might not
sound like a lot,
but on Frontier,
that's a round trip to Orlando.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Sam Adams
is offering to pay
$10,000 wedding bar tab
for couples who include
Sam Adams summer ale
in their wedding vows.
[ Laughter ]
This is great.
Half the grooms in Boston
already planned on saying it,
but now they might get paid.
[ Laughter ]
Not to be outdone, you can also
win 10% off the cocktail hour
if the priest yells, "Hebrew
National pigs in a blanket."
This is very exciting.
Today, New York ended its
pandemic state of emergency.
It's over.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But, unfortunately,
that also means
the end of to-go cocktails...
[ Audience boos ]
...marking the first time
anyone's been nostalgic
for 2020.
It's too bad.
I'm really gonna miss
seeing delivery guys
balance yardstick margaritas
on their E-bikes.
Whoa-a-a-a.
Speaking of New York, the state
just suspended Rudy Giuliani
from practicing law
'cause of...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...'cause of his repeated false
and misleading statements
about the election.
Even Rudy was like, "What
the hell took you so long?"
You know you've crossed a line
when other lawyers are like,
"This guy lies way too much."
It's a mixed bag for Rudy.
The bad news -- he can't
practice law in New York.
The good news -- he can't defend
himself at his next trial.
Meanwhile, when the news
about Rudy broke,
his son Andrew
released a video statement.
Watch this.
-As you may have heard recently,
a few minutes ago,
my father's law license
was suspended
by the New York state
First Appellate Division
of the Supreme Court.
This is unacceptable,
and I stand by my father.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-The top 20% of his body
stands with his father.
What did he use to film that?
A truck's rear-view camera?
Like, "Just put it in reverse
and hit 'record.'
Hey, I'll lay on the ground."
-[ Imitating backup signal ]
-Rudy saw his son giving
a speech in a random parking lot
and was like,
"I've taught him so well."
[ Laughter ]
Some more legal news.
A 49-year-old woman from Indiana
just became the first person
to be sentenced
for storming the Capitol,
receiving three years
of probation and a $500 fine.
Yeah, the woman said
she learned her lesson
and hopes Trump pardons her
when he's reinstated
as President in August.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
Hey, here's some good news.
Today after meeting with
a bipartisan group of senators,
President Biden
finally announced
that they had a deal
on infrastructure.
Yeah. right now,
New Yorkers are thinking,
"Okay, now, team up, and let's
save to-go cocktails.
Let's go. That's the real --
Let's get to the -- Come on!"
[ Applause ]
That's right, Republicans and
Democrats working together --
amazing.
It's like one of
those YouTube videos
of a lion making friends
with a squirrel.
You know? It's possible.
The compromise was actually
not that difficult.
All it took was hard work,
determination,
and a blow dart
to Mitch McConnell's neck.
[ Exhales sharply, groans ]
-"I've been hit."
-Well, the President
held a press conference
to discuss the big
infrastructure deal,
which brings us to
a new piece called
"Joe Biden, Whisperer-in-Chief."
♪♪
-And he said, "People
are waiting for relief."
[Whispering ] I got them
$1.9 trillion of relief so far.
Just remind them, I wrote
the bill on the environment.
[ Normal voice ] When employers
can't find workers,
I said, "Yeah [whispering]
pay them more."
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-I love it.
-Wow.
-[ Laughing ]
-He closed by saying
[whispering] "If you build it,
they will come."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Well,
some business news.
After disappointing sales,
Dunkin' Donuts
has pulled the Beyond Meat
breakfast sandwich
from their national menu.
-Oh, come on!
-Yep. Dunkin' was shocked
plant-based foods
didn't appeal to
the same customers
who eat strawberry frosting
for breakfast.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
I read a headline today
that kind of confused me.
It said, "T-Mobile released
its own 5G-inspired gin,"
which brings us to a segment
we like to call
"Uhh...I Have Some Questions."
-♪ I have some questions ♪
-First up, why is a phone
company releasing its own gin?
Actually, hold on.
What does it mean
to be "5G-inspired"?
Like, does the gin
taste like a 5G network?
Wait, back up.
Where would I even buy
T-Mobile gin?
Do I have to track down
a T-Mobile store,
and, if so, do they offer
unlimited gin plans?
Follow-up -- Is it cheaper
if my whole family
is on the same gin plan?
But what if my wife
doesn't like gin?
What if my kids love gin?
And again, what is
"5G-inspired"?
I just have so many questions.
-♪ I just have
so many questions ♪
-And finally, a new survey found
that nearly half of American men
experimented with their look
last year.
Experimenting with your look
is one way of putting it.
I mean, guys were cutting
their hair with nail clippers.
Well, guys,
in a speech last night,
former Vice President Mike Pence
made his clearest effort yet
to distance himself from Trump
by saying he was proud
to certify the election.
Wow.
This is a whole different side
of Pence.
[ Laughter ]
Next he says he wants to be
grand marshal
of the pride parade.
I mean, it's amazing
what's happening to him.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Trump can't believe
Pence turned against him.
He was like, "Boy, just when
you think you know a guy
that you sent an angry mob
into the Capitol building
to murder."
[ Laughter ]
Pence also tried to
lighten the mood
by telling a joke,
and he delivered it
as only Mike Pence can.
-There was this farmer
who decided to take his cow
to market.
So he loaded the cow
in the truck and the dog
and headed into town.
But on his way there,
there was a traffic accident.
Cow and the truck
went in one ditch,
and the farmer and the dog
went in the other.
They ended up in court.
And the attorney for the other
driver was questioning,
"Isn't it true that you said you
never felt better in your life?"
He said, "Sir, would you like to
explain the circumstances
in which you made that comment?"
He said, "Yeah,
I reckon I would.
Me and the cow
was in one ditch,
and the truck and dog
was in the other.
And I seen the sheriff,
and he walked over,
he looked down at that dog.
It had a broke back --
it wasn't going to get better.
He got his revolver out and
put it next to the dog's ear,
and he shot him.
And again, he mercifully
put his revolver
to the forehead of that cow
and pulled the trigger.
Then that sheriff walked over
to me and said,
'And how are you feeling?'"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-Wow!
Then Pence was like,
"D-Darn, I told it wrong.
Let me try it again
from the top.
There was this farmer,
he was in a ditch."
What was that joke?
Seriously.
If you're looking to break up
your Fourth of July barbecue,
tell that one.
I mean, that's --
[ Laughter ]
Shooting the dog?
-Broken back.
-"Pulled his revolver out
and aimed at dog."
-"He wasn't gonna get
any better."
-It got worse
when the camera panned out
and it was just a group of
preschool kids.
And they go, "Oh."
Awful.
[ Laughter ]
Get this. According to
a new book coming out,
Trump made fun, apparently,
of Rudy Giuliani
for spitting during meetings.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
And even told him
that he sucked on TV.
[ Laughter ]
Spitting, sucking, sweating,
leaking --
he's like every awful guy
at Planet Fitness
rolled into one guy, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Rudy took it all
in stride, though.
He's like, "Look, he teases me,
but at the end of the day,
he also ruined my life."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, today,
Vice President Kamala Harris
made her first visit
to the U.S./Mexico border.
Yeah, she visited
the border town of El Paso.
Is it me or "El Paso" is not
the best name for a border town?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-How about No Pass-O?
[ Applause ]
Some business news.
Popeyes just introduced
the new "I Don't Know" meal
for people who can't decide
what to order.
How can you be undecided
when the entire menu
has basically one thing?
[ Laughter ]
It's not like
customers are thinking,
"Should I have the fried
chicken or the, uh, sushi?
What do you think?
What do you think
I should have at Popeyes?"
[ Laughter ]
"How fresh are
the lobster tails?"
[ Laughter ]
Actually, they offer
the same meal at Arby's,
only it's the cook
who has no idea what's in it.
-Oh, there you go.
-"I don't know.
Uh, no, hey.
It's bleeding, whatever it is,
so I don't know.
It's something."
-"Yes, sir."
-And get this, astronomers
have identified
a "extremely eccentric
mini planet"
that just entered
our solar system,
and it's on course
to pass by Earth.
It's pretty exciting,
but we were curious what exactly
is an extremely
eccentric mini planet?
So here now
to talk about their trip
is the extremely
eccentric mini planet.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ British accent ]
Oh, my God.
Jimmy, I can't believe I'm here.
This is so random.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not too random.
We did invite you.
-Totally.
It's just that astronomers
are always telling me
I'm so eccentric.
You know, first they'll be like,
"Look at that normal planet
over there."
But then I'll be like, "Um,
I'm not like the other planets.
I'm a semi-amateur
craft cocktail mixologist."
Hello?
-Uh-huh.
So what exactly makes you
an eccentric planet?
-Well, my taste in music
is super-eclectic.
Like, sometimes I listen
to Lady Gaga,
but then sometimes
I listen to, like, a podcast.
It's like my mind
is on shuffle.
[ Laughter ]
-And that classifies you as an
extremely eccentric planet?
-Well, technically,
it's because I'm so small.
Because people --
people are always telling me
"Oh my gosh, Planet,
you're so fit."
And I'm like, "Um, you haven't
seen me on Taco Tuesday."
[ Laughs ]
-Well, maybe you could compare
and contrast yourself
with another planet.
-Sure.
So, like, Mars is red
and has a couple moons, right?
-Sure.
-Normal planet.
Whereas I collect
Funko Pop! figurines
and have a mustache tattoo
on my index finger.
Eccentric! Eccentric!
-Yeah, you're very eccentric.
I got it. I got it.
I got it.
Give me another example.
-Or, like, Earth has water
and can sustain life, right?
-Yeah.
-Normal planet.
Whereas I perform ukulele covers
of rap songs on Periscope.
Extremely eccentric.
-One last thing. That's not --
[ Chuckles ]
That's not --
That's not your
real accent, is it?
-[ American accent ]
No, it's completely fake.
-All right, good.
Thank you.
The extremely eccentric
mini planet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ] My gosh.
He's a-dork-ably eccentric.
-Yeah, a-dork-ably.
-And finally,
earlier this week,
police in Pennsylvania
broke up an exorcism
in the lumber aisle
of a Home Depot.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, an exorcism
in the lumber aisle.
Police laughed until
the 2x4 projectile vomited.
[ Laughter ]
Then they held a seance to
summon a being from far beyond,
a Home Depot employee.
"Does anyone work here?"